Speaker 1: . OK, one other similar story about
new reporting that we have.
Earlier this week, I told you about the forthcoming
book, I Alone Can Fix It by Washington Post
reporters Carol Leonnig and Philip Rucker.
And during the week, there have been little
leaks about what is in that book.
There is now a New York magazine report with
more information about what's in it and also
some CNN reports.
And what is in this book is absolutely and
totally wild.
Let's first look at some CNN published quotes
from the book, starting with Donald Trump
talking about the German chancellor, Angela
Merkel.
You know, Joe Biden today is meeting with
Angela Merkel and will be doing a press conference
with her.
My sense is that Biden's perspective on Merkel
is different than Trump's.
Donald Trump reportedly said in the Oval Office,
quote, That bitch Merkel as well as I know
the effing Krauts.
And I was raised by the biggest crowd of the
small crowd, of course, a pejorative for German
people.
Trump reportedly referring to the chancellor
as that bitch.
Merkel also reported in this book, General
Mark Milley was worried about how do we protect
the inauguration.
And Molly reportedly said, quote, Here's the
deal, guys.
These guys are Nazis.
They're boogaloo boys.
They're proud boys.
These are the same people we fought in World
War Two.
And then lastly, from CNN's reporting on quotes
from the book, I alone can fix it.
Nancy Pelosi reportedly saying of Trump after
January 6th, this guy's crazy, he's dangerous.
He's a maniac.
We have deep concerns.
The New York magazine report outlining that
Mark Milley said Trump preached, quote, the
gospel of the Führer, referring to Adolf
Hitler.
Gen. Mark Milley, the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff, likened Donald Trump's effort
to hold on to power after the twenty twenty
election to Adolf Hitler, saying the president
was preaching the gospel of the Führer with
his lies about the election being stolen.
According to the book, I Alone Can Fix It
by Carol Leonnig and Philip Rucker, the Pentagon's
top general said shortly before the January
6th insurrection that Trump had led the country
to the brink of its own Reichstag moment,
viewing him as a potential threat to the American
democracy.
It seems very clear that Mark Milley, you
know what?
You actually know what's really funny about
this?
Was it last week or the week before that we
had that clip of Mark Milley saying during
a hearing, hey, guys, listen, just because
you learn about critical race theory doesn't
mean you become some kind of cartoon WOAK
character in the same way that Mark Milley
said, we are a university at the military
and we want to learn about Marxism.
We want to learn about communism.
We want to learn about critical race theory.
We want to understand what are the beliefs
of people within the country and outside of
it.
It's it's quite clear, you know, whatever
you want to think about Mark Milley, that
the fact that he's a.
Part of history has served him quite well
in being able to look at the past and find
situations that are analogous to what we saw
under Donald Trump.
The article points out Trump had appointed
me to be chairman of the Joint Chiefs in twenty
eighteen over the objection of Defense Secretary
James Mattis.
The Army generals tenure at the top of the
Pentagon at the top of the Pentagon had been
relatively quiet until last summer when he
appeared in uniform during an infamous photo
op for Trump in Lafayette Square that followed.
The clearing of protesters in front of the
White House merely apologized for creating
a perception of the military involved in domestic
politics.
Although the book chronicles Milli's concerns
with Trump dating back to that moment, the
generals worries grew rapidly as Trump plunged
the nation into chaos following Election Day.
Seven days later, Milley got a call from an
old friend with an explicit warning that Trump
and his allies were trying to overturn the
government.
Millie was confident that any attempts by
Trump to hold on to power would be thwarted
because the military wouldn't go along.
They may try, but they're not going to effing
succeed, he told aides.
You can't do this without the military.
You can't do this without the CIA and FBI.
We're the guys with the guns.
Still, Millie was disturbed by the sight of
Trump supporters rallying to his cause in
November, calling them brownshirts in the
streets.
Leonnig and Rucker wrote that, quote, believed
Trump was stoking unrest, possibly in hopes
of an excuse to invoke the Insurrection Act
and call out the military.
Even at that high level, there was the fear
that that's what Donald Trump wanted to do,
a key difference between Trump's dictatorial
delusions and those of Adolf Hitler.
Trump is in his mid 70s, Hitler was in his
40s when the Reichstag burned.
Trump could still get a good run if he were
reelected in twenty four.
Right.
But it is a different situation in that sense.
Significant, significantly different age.
I actually am looking forward to this book.
I alone can fix it.
Normally, I'm not big on these books, but
this one I do plan
to read.